i know when i should start saying these
things we're
recording and you can start anytime okay
this is division three
and here's the prelude i guess as
chair division three of the house
finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body body is authorized to
meet electronically
this is a public meeting pertaining to
division orientation matters
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access
to contemporaneously listen and if
necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information
has been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should email
lba underscore fiscal
at leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled lba staff
are on the meeting assisting us please
note that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
and as an aside i don't interes we don't
anticipate any votes being taken
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there's anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is acquired under the right to no
law can you handle that harry for me
please
sure thank you representative walner
representative walters present and i'm
in my home in concord
and i'm alone
representative nordgren representative
pardon me represent northwind i'm here
in my dining room in hanover
with by myself
representative rogers i'm representative
kathryn rogers i am in my
apartment in concord with my dog romeo
representative uh president i'm in home
alone
in my home office representative weiler
who guess who's missing representative
edwards
is also missing i'm representative bean
i'm at my home in guilford and i'm
alone okay
so i'll close this and
who am i starting with
good morning representative
i can jump right in oh karen hi
i'm always i couldn't find the face i
won't be on camera today i apologize for
that um no problem
so i uh if you're ready we can turn it
right over to deb
sheets she will share her screen and
begin the presentation for long-term
supports and services
great thank you karen you're welcome
so karen have you
spoken to this group before deborah i'm
sorry
so this is the first time that deb is
presenting
um to the committee jane jackson who's
the finance director she has been
uh with us before for behavioral health
uh she is the finance director for both
of those divisions but this is the first
time deb has been with us
so i just want to give her a heads up
about the way we do things so can you
see me in your screen uh deb
yes i can representative her so i'm
apparently supposed to like
waive you to get your attention um
hopefully between your
breaths i'll try to keep an eye on other
people as well for their hands being
raised but if other people raise their
hands and i don't catch them
feel free to interrupt me okay thank you
representative
thank you with that i'm going to go
ahead and get started because
um we have a bit to get through today so
i just want to take an opportunity to
let you know that
jane jackson is the finance manager for
long-term supports and services in
addition to behavioral health and she'll
be joining us today
also joining us on the call today and
who is available for questions
is david weiters who's direct director
of information services here at
dhhs because i'm going to be talking a
little bit about information technology
at the start of the presentation
and henry lipman will also be joining us
uh to go through a couple of the items
relative to beas when we get there
so with that i just want to begin with a
brief overview of the division of
long-term supports and services
um the division was established in 2017
and includes three bureaus the bureau of
developmental services which has four
major program areas which we will
discuss
later on the bureau of family centered
services which has three major programs
which we will get into later on
and the bureau of elderly and adult
services which has
nine major programs in state fiscal year
the expense for these programs came to
796 million dollars
this represents 32 accounting units over
the three bureaus
and we will be getting into details
around those
accounting units and what our sfy 2223
budget looks like moving forward
so as you've seen in previous
presentations
um the division of long term supports
and services
is part of the human services and
behavioral health
uh component within the department of
health and human services
we work in partnership with medicaid i
believe henry lippman yesterday
described medicaid as a team approach
and you will see that out of that 700
um million dollars a good portion of the
financing
is medicaid match specific however we do
have
other funding streams which we will get
into and explain in just a moment
when it comes to the division of
long-term supports and services
the bureaus are brought together because
essentially
we help people from literally the ages
of zero to three
with early intervention services all the
way through
helping our seniors with nursing
facility care and
home and community-based supports in
addition we also support those with
developmental disabilities
once they exit the school system and go
into adult services so it's a wide range
of services and we have an opportunity
to work with a terrific
array of providers and area agencies and
case management agencies that we'll be
talking about as well a little further
down the line
so within the division of long-term
supports and services
we as i mentioned a good portion of our
funding comes from medicaid
and that medicaid funding helps support
our 4 1915 c home in community-based
waivers
and our federal partners are the center
for medicare and medicaid services
in addition medicaid helps cover the
nursing facility costs along with our
partners from the counties
and we'll be talking more about that
when we discuss the bureau of elderly
adult services
we also have four other funding streams
that are braided
into providing services for seniors and
for children and for adults with
disabilities
the funding streams include the hrsa
funding stream which you'll re
we'll we will be referring to as title 5
funding so i know that you've got your
acronyms in front of you so that's hr
we also have the federal office for
special education funding
stream which is our part c early
intervention or early supports and
services
we also receive funding from the
administration for community living
which includes title three two and four
funding
and we also receive funding from the
administration for children and families
which is our title
20 funding so we have a wide variety of
partners
that we have to meet compliance
requirements for
whether it's through grant funding or
medicaid funding
and we have a terrific team that works
very hard to make sure that we
ensure that we protect those matches and
those dollars as they come into the
state
so we do have some key challenges and i
think some of the challenges will be
reminiscent of the challenges that you
have heard about to date from
other divisions within the department of
health and human services
i wanted to focus in on workforce to
begin with
um within the workforce i would break it
up into two different categories
category number one would be workforce
shortages within our bureaus
which is resulting in challenges for
operations and oversight
in the department in the division of
long-term supports and services we have
a total of 153 positions
131 positions are filled right now and
occupied
and 22 are vacant um
so when i take a look at what we need to
achieve
when it comes to transactions operations
and transformation it makes it rather
difficult to move into transformation
and building new programs
and creating partnerships with our
stakeholder community to advance our
services
because of the fact that we quite
frankly are understaffed at this point
in time
and we spend a lot of time focusing on
our transactions and operations to
protect our match with medicaid as well
as to ensure that we
continue to get our grant funding from
our federal partners
um as an example the bureau for family
centered services has been operating at
a 41
vacancy rate for the past six months
this is due to a high retirement rate
um the division of long-term supports
and services like the rest of the
department
has seen a significant number of
retirements during the covid
epidemic and i know that
deputy commissioner weaver spoke
to some of the challenges that we've had
in terms of staffing
another area that uh i know that many of
you have heard about
especially relative to clovid because
covet has really put
a spotlight on workforce capacity issues
and that comes to us being able to
appropriately staff our nursing
facilities
as well as our home and community-based
services
we continue to have issues in terms of
attracting individuals to this
sector or to this segment to be employed
and to be able to work with our provider
community to deliver services
another area that we have faced key
challenges on is relative to inter
information technology and i'm going to
get very specific about that in the next
couple of slides
but the bottom line is that the bureau
of elderly and adult services
is working with the 23 year old system
right now
to be able to administer on many of our
programs including our adult
protective services programs and this is
posing problems moving forward and we
have a capital request in that
for our bureau of developmental services
we have
a series of disparate and aged systems
one of the systems that we work with
with our area agency system
is new hampshire leads and that dates
from 1998
we also have what's known as a budget
tracking system which dates from
2007. um so both of
so when you take a look at our bureau
supports we are definitely challenged
when it comes to
processing the work and getting the
access to data in
information to inform policy making
lastly
we have multiple funding streams and
it's a challenge relative to compliance
and oversight because we need to make
sure
at all costs that we are delivering
quality product
and that we are meeting all the
requirements set forth in our funded
with from our funding partners
excuse me i believe representative
rogers has a question for you
yeah i'm not sure deb if this is the
proper place to ask but when you talk
about
the workforce and your shortages is
there a rate increase
in this budget i didn't notice or didn't
know where to find it
but is there a rate increase for any of
your workforce included in here
and if not did you ask for one okay
so we did zero in um within the beas
budget and we'll get into it a little
bit later on but just to give you a
preview now
three areas for rate increases the first
area is case management
for our cfi case managers and that will
be part of the cfi
case management rate increase and
representative
rogers because of the work that you did
on the parity committee
a couple of years ago you know that that
was a commitment that the department
made to move that
forward and we are doing so in this
budget request
a second area is for personal care
services in the cfi
um waiver and we're looking for our rate
increase there that we can get into more
detail
on later on and then the third area is
homemaker services where we have put in
for a rate increase
those went in in the department phase as
a prioritized need
and those are included in the governor's
budget
is that it you know kathy yep um i also
have a question for you
just when you when we get to go into the
accounts would you draw
our attention to the accounts that
relate to these systems you were talking
about
yes um absolutely because they are
actually not in the beas budget but they
are in the capital budget so i'm going
to quickly go through them
now representative okay okay
so moving forward um there are four
capital projects
and the first one is the bds direct
billing project
and this is a project that is going to
help us meet
our corrective action plan with our
federal partners for the centers for
medicare medicaid services
and this ffp is at ninety percent
and so the net to the state for this
project is a hundred thousand dollars
and this will allow us to meet our
requirements
in terms of the corrective action plan
the second system
is the developmental services i.t
remediation system
and again this is a 90 match
all right with our federal partners and
the net to the state would be 1.3
million
approximately and this is a project that
is
of extreme import because these are the
systems that date from
1998 and from 2007
and we are hard pressed to provide for
compliance oversight and operations with
our current
systems infrastructure
the next uh system that we have put in
as for part of the capital
uh uh budget is the electronic visit
verification system
otherwise known as evv and this
is required by the 21st century
cures act and uh for us to be able to
deliver
this system it will come once again with
a 90
match in the state net for this one will
be 566
000 and this is a mission critical
system
in that it allows us to be able to
take a look at gaps and services that
allows us to affirm that the services
are actually being delivered
and it also decreases any potential or
opportunity for fraud
and right now if we do not deliver this
we will be
receiving a penalty from our partners
from medicaid that will
directly hit the state and david wieders
is available if you have any questions
in regards to this
any further the two systems that
i'd like to call attention to because we
have done a lot of requirements work and
are literally at a point where we could
go out in rfp
or the evv system because prior to this
we worked with mercer we had an rfp that
was put out
and we have defined the systems
requirements and we
can move on this very very quickly and
hopefully put ourselves into compliance
so we are not looking at a penalty
for the developmental services i.t
remediation system we have been working
with public consulting group and we've
completed
uh systems requirements for this as well
and we are at a point where we could
move this forward rapidly to get
into actual system builds and to see
some relief when it comes to
compliance oversight operations
the last system is the beas
modernization and this is
a different system in that it is not a
medicaid based system but it falls
under a 60 40 so it would be a 40
match so the net to the state would be a
little
over 4 million and again it's a
different math
matching uh approach so is the slide
incorrect or
are you talking a different system that
slide is correct it should indicate
40 not 90 representative irf and i will
make sure that that's adjusted when we
submit
i'll resubmit that to kevin so that you
have it
know that we have done some extensive
work here as well we've done a full lean
analysis where we've defined measured
analyzed and figured out what needs to
be improved and what controls
need to be put in place using the
demaiock model
and um it's important to note that if we
do not get this system
we believe that we we would be looking
at hiring an additional four and a half
people
to do this work manually and
quite honestly it would still not help
us in terms of getting
improved service authorizations taking a
look at case loads
helping make sure that we can process
registry requests
for background checks so that nursing
facilities can move
quickly to be able to hire people so we
can process things more effectively
there's a lot of human intensive
data entry right now which comes with
thick thumbs and can pose issues down
the line
and we believe that there is a far more
effective approach that we can take
relative to our systems in the division
of long-term supports and services
deborah i believe representative wallner
has a question for you
i do yeah but you um
refer to these as capital projects are
these
in the operating budget or are do we
are they in the capital budget these are
in the capital budget
okay thank you so really they're not
before this committee they're before
the public works committee they are and
i wanted to call your attention to it
because
for us to be able to be effective in our
transactions and operations we need
these systems
but for us to be able to transform
and to be able to do
work that results in better services
when it comes to the way that we deliver
services
our information technology is a
foundation
to be able to do that so when i talk to
you
about our operations and our budgets
here within division three
i wanted to call attention and connect
to the fact that we need an
infrastructure built
within long-term supports and services
to be able to
deliver better services to be able to
work more effectively with our providers
and to consider new ways of delivering
services that will result in better
quality for the people we serve
and efficiencies right thank you for
clearing that up
thanks just one question later that
deborah um
are any aspects of these systems these
installation of these systems
including the operational budget
uh no this is entirely capital
okay thank you all right and i just want
to uh
reach out to david weiters to see if he
is on the line kevin
and if you would like to add anything
relative to this
sure let me just bring him in thank you
representative bean has note that
representative weiler is present now
and uh dave should be in here now
he would need to meet himself he wants
to talk but he is there
i apologize yes i was just trying to
find that mute button
um my name is david weeders information
services director for health and human
services
and deb sheets actually covered it very
very well
the only the only addition i have is the
bureau of elderly and adult services
modernization
was brought up at the capitol project
hearing with the public works committee
that that project was not in the
governor's submittal
it was one of the items that we
suggested that the committee consider
moving that forward as well so that we
could
really address the the deferred
maintenance that we've had on systems
across the board in dhhs but
specifically in long-term supports and
services
these systems are critical for for them
to be able to provide the
ongoing operations and maintenance so
without these systems
the operations um expenditures are
dependent upon them so we really
we wanted to tie them together and
that's why you're hearing about them
today
i don't have anything else to add just
to clarify you're saying that none of
these projects were included in the
governor's capital
uh for clarification the the first three
that she referred to
the electronic visit verification system
the bd
the um i t the developmental services i
t
remediation and i'm going to get the
name wrong on the other one
electronic visitor verification the
third one
filling the development or the bds track
the remediation
and the electronic visit verification
were included it
was not was the bureau of elderly and
adult services modernization but i do
want to call attention to this because i
do see this as a mission critical system
that is 23 years old and
i think that when you get right down to
it we need the infrastructure to be able
to operate beas
and be able to ensure that we can
operate our aps program
thank you for the clarification
i don't think there's any other
questions so go on ahead
all right so i'm going to move forward
and
i'm also going to talk a little bit
about the alvarez and marcel
report that will be published shortly
and
there were some very specific uh
recommendations for the developmental
services system
the first uh was the recommendation that
the
bureau of developmental services take a
look at a
waiver redesign and right now the
developmental disability waiver is a
single comprehensive waiver
and the a m report indicates that the
state should consider taking a tiered
weaver
approach which is something that when it
is published you can
take a look at and get some additional
information on
and the report also asks us to consider
developing tiered reimbursement rates
now um i think it's important to note
that the dd
waiver uh in sfy 20 was about
280.2 million um
and uh it's also interesting to note
there
that point seven percent of the dd
population
account for five percent of the total
dd waiver budget and those individuals
that
account for that higher percentage of
spend
are individuals that receive intensive
treatment services and residential
options right now we have quite a few
out-of-state placements and
related to the waiver redesign and the
reimbursement rates
is the recommendation that a m has made
that we develop
in-state intensive treatment services
and
i believe that that is an important
factor moving forward
because it will allow us to keep
individuals
in state with their natural supports it
will allow
us to develop this high higher level
high need
service and hopefully do so at a cost
that is less
than sending people out of state for
services
as well it will also help
the bureau develop in cooperation with
the area agencies and providers
a continuum of care that takes into
account
serving the highest level of highest
need
and again i'm going to circle back to
the fact that the a
m recommendation really emphasizes the
import
of having an information technology
system to support
our operations so that we in turn can
support
transformation which would include a
waiver
redesigned to tiered waivers as well as
tiered reimbursement rates
so all of these are directly connected
and when the report comes out you will
be able to read that which will tie
into the hb2 10 million dollar figure
that representative walner was asking
about yesterday
with director lipman can you provide any
insight as to why
we don't have that report when we're
expected to
fund 10 million dollars to implement
that report
um just being posted but i'd ask karen
rounds to
uh just give an update on where that is
it there was some finalization that
needed to happen to it
and so it is um just about finalized
i really hope that it will be public
this week okay i mean i don't know what
you what you mean by public hearing
because we're not really the public
um you are you are the public any
anything i provide to you is public
information
okay i mean it's a little frustrating to
us that we have to consider a 10 million
dollar
expense and we can't see what's behind
it i understand
okay uh mr representative weiler has a
question i believe
thank you mr chairman from experience in
the past with reports
that are slow in being published and
sometimes not totally available
and what i've discovered is that you're
negotiating with people to change what
was written
because it was too critical or it might
have done
something might have said something like
you've got too many middle
managers or you paying your people too
much so those are the kind of things
that we don't want to see
exposed this may not be the case at all
but it's
what my experience in the past has told
me when there's a report
that is slow to come to those of us that
paid for it
it's because of these reasons that
there's negotiations going on to change
and that's i'm sorry that's my
suspicions
and i can i can certainly appreciate
that representative but
i can assure you that that's not what's
happening um
there there's definitely not any
negotiation around what the report says
thank you you're welcome
so to summarize um what we have
is a case of my apologies
what we have is the report indicating
that we have
inadequate information technology to
collect and analyze data
and that we have inadequate controls for
aligning services to assess need
which means that there may be instances
where we may be over serving somebody
or underserving somebody and what we
want to do is make sure that every
individual gets the services that they
need
based on their level of care and the
recommendations from alvarez and marcel
are very very specific
in terms of what the department can do
to address those issues
and we do have some gaps in system
controls that are outlined in the report
as well
and again the information technology
foundation
the waiver redesign and the tiered
reimbursement rates will go a long way
to try and remediate some of this and
in terms of a continuum of care we
are unable to deliver a lot of necessary
intensive treatment services
in state so a question related to
the 10 million dollars for the alvarez
and marcel and the
fact that the governor didn't include
the more expensive of your capital
projects the most expensive i guess
which one would you prioritize the
infrared stuff or the
federal or the um the bureau of elderly
adult services modernization
technology so representative earth i'd
like to
just um go back and indicate that the
governor did prioritize
um bds developmental services i.t
remediation which is noted here by
alvarez and marcel
an electronic visit verification
my understanding is that the beas
modernization was not included
and um i would just like to lean into
david to see if he has anything to add
well just to clarify so you're saying
that all four of those systems were part
are are part of the a m report
but the okay so i'm not quite sure what
your
comment how your comment is my question
let me rephrase my question
okay the the a m is budgeted at about 10
million dollars in
hb2 the beas
which i understand the bureau of elect
of elderly and adult services
modernization which i understand
not in the governor's budget capital
budget appropriation
and that's roughly what forty percent
sixty percent of eight million dollars
so it's several million dollars
it's not insubstantial i'm just
wondering which you prioritize more
highly
the things that the a m report is
talking about or this particular
system that was not included in the
capital projects
so the a m report calls attention to
and prioritizes the developmental
services i.t
remediation all right and
points that out as being essential to to
conduct system transformation
that is included in the capital projects
i got that
what about the elderly adult services
modernization system
are you asking me to choose which one of
my children i want
oh the the one so that's the
developmental height
the first one is not a 10 million dollar
system it is like a million bucks
bds direct billing has a stat a state
net of 100k
right it developmental services i t
remediation has
a state net of 1.3 million right so
that's that's inconsistent not
inconsequential but it's way less than
10 million dollars
so of the other 9 million dollars
of the a m report is is the other nine
million or most of it a higher priority
than
the for you then for your department my
understanding and correct me if i'm
wrong and i'll yield to karen on this
is that the operations of the 10 million
does not include
the i.t component please correct karen
i believe that's correct and if you were
asking the department to prioritize we
would say that
the uh implementation of what is in the
a
m report is a priority for the
department
okay so this is not in the a m report
the the this particular system
no so the what's in the report is is the
developmental disabilities piece
and that is within the capital budget i
got that but the
bureau of elderly and assault services
modernization piece is not in the report
no it is not in the a m report okay
thank you and uh representative weiler
has a question
uh thank you mr chairman so
the we have a department of like
information technology
were they involved all in any of these
decisions of
not funding this
i guess mr wieders i don't know whether
he's directly employed by them or he's
just
their coordinator or how it works
the full department of i.t were they any
support or were they any
uh advice on this um thank you
representative weiler
and mr chair that's a good question we
certainly
we coordinate with information the
department of information technology and
we create what's an a
what's called an agency information
technology strategic plan
with them and then what happens is
commissioner goulet
actually works to prioritize those
projects
with the department as well as across
the whole state and then submits those
projects
for for review by the governor's office
we certainly have prioritizing as
as representative irf indicated which
one would we do first which one would do
we do second bds direct billing was
not at the top of the list so we
basically got
the top 11 projects moved forward
through the governor's process
for the house to review in the public
works
committee and commissioner goulet and
myself presented
on this past friday on those projects
together so they certainly we we
integrate we
we leverage doit we can't live without
them
my role for the department is to
coordinate our strategic plan
as well as our security data warehousing
and overall
application life cycle management thank
you mr wieders
representative walner your question yes
i do
um i was wondering how was
the disabilities community
and uh maybe the area agencies involved
in the development of this report
so uh the report uh calls for um
extreme comprehensive stakeholder
engagement over at least a one year
period with the area agency system
and with providers and most importantly
with the individuals that receive
these services as many of you are aware
that the disability community
has long maintained nothing about us
without us
and part of the a m report takes that
into consideration
and we have a one-year stakeholder
engagement period which will help with
systems requirements which will help
with
the way that we redesign the waivers we
want input
we want to work collaboratively to bring
the system to the next level
and that is the intent and that is
clearly outlined in the a
m report and it's something the
commissioner felt very strongly about
thank you deb i appreciate that
i'm sorry feel free to go on no i'm i'm
that was my question oh no i was talking
to deborah
all right so what i wanted to do is
give you this um landscape approach
look at where we are within the division
of long-term supports and services and
then i'm going to go through each of the
bureaus
and ask my bureau chiefs to join us
during that
during those presentations but again
what i wanted to do
is to give you context for the a m
recommendation and how that fits
with our budgeting approach in sfy 2223
and also the need for information
technology and infrastructure builds and
how that fits in
so thank you for your patience and as
soon as the report
is up i'm sure that there will be a lot
of people reviewing that to see the good
that can come out of that
those recommendations so thank you just
let me
excuse myself for one moment how
representative editors you want to um
step into the driver's seat no no you're
doing great
okay so next what i would like to do
is review the bureau of elderly and
adult services
and what i'd like to do is ask kevin if
he could bring
wendy altman in as well as
medicaid director henry lippman as well
to join us
around that and i want to thank david
for joining us for the first portion
of the presentation so the bureau of
elderly and adult services
has a responsibility and a mission to
help
provide comprehensive and coordinated
services for older adults
60 plus as well as adults with
disabilities that range in age from 18
to 59.
the state serves as the designated state
agency
on aging under the under uh under the
older americans act
and what we do is we work very hard in
partnership with case management
agencies and providers to ensure the
right
safety independence and dignity of
adults
and we do our absolute best to support
people and prevent
abuse neglect and exploitation we
administer the choices for independence
home and community-based 1915
c waiver that you will recall is one of
the four
1915 c waivers within the division of
long-term supports and services
and we work very hard to set policy
and program implementation for other
funding streams that we discussed
earlier on i think it is very important
to take a look at where we are as a
state and our changing demographics
i think that right now when you take a
look at this in front of you you can see
that new hampshire is growing and by
2030 over one third of new hampshire's
population
will be over 65 years of age and
and when you take a look at the
demographics the number of 85 plus
increases significantly as well so
between now and 2050
we are looking at an older new hampshire
and what we want to do
is we want to ensure that people have
the right to choose the types of
services they want and how they want to
live their lives whether it be in the
home in community
or whether eventually it be through
assisted living or nursing facilities as
part of a continuum of care
i wanted to explain a little bit about
um bea
operations and how we are organized and
this gives you an
idea of the lift that we have as an
operation
we have a long-term care policy unit
which has seven
staff and they provide contract
oversight for 53 contracts
they do grant management they provide
oversight for the care path and service
link programs which i will discuss
very briefly moving forward and they are
responsible for program coordination
training and technical assistance we
also have
the state unit on aging which includes
two staff
the bureau chief wendy altman and an
administrative assistants and we are
responsible for
ensuring that we have a state plan on
aging we are responsible for cfi waiver
management
as well as public partner correspondence
and other items
we also have the adult protective
services
group which has 61 staff across
our district offices and they are
responsible for intaking
aps cases the state registry
investigations for somebody who may
be at risk or be in harm's way whether
it be financially or for the way that
they are living
their lives independently and they do a
lot of outreach
and efforts in education and training so
that we get
the appropriate level of reporting to
protect people
and then we also have a long-term care
eligibility eligibility unit
that provides the medical eligibility
for the level of care for people who
are applying for and receive eventually
receiving services
upon approval we also have an
information
systems group that includes four staff
that help with help desk support
provider relations
and reports and analysis for our ongoing
operations within beas
is the long-term care medical facility
an actual facility that
does long-term care or you just the
where the processing happens
it's where the processing happens
representative earth okay
thank you okay but direct service
delivery
is through our adult protective services
and those are 61
individuals that work directly with
people at risk
so in terms of the way that we are
organized as i said the adult protective
services we those are state employees
they
are work out of the 11 district offices
for the choices for independence waiver
we work with independent organizations
senior
centers nutrition providers assisted
living providers in a variety of
community-based organizations
we have 221 enrolled providers
at statewide level and at the regional
level
and we have one contract for what's
known as pasar or level of care reviews
for elderly and adult service providers
that are
separate from our medicaid cfi waiver
we receive our funding through the older
americans act and through social
services block grants and again we lean
into independent organizations community
action
agencies senior centers nutrition
providers and area
agencies and we have 45 contracted
providers
and most of them cover a particular
county
and 13 do offer services statewide
and of course most of you are familiar
with the collaboration
and long history that we have working on
with our nursing facilities with our
counties
and with our for-profit and non-profit
nursing facilities
we currently have 71 nursing facilities
and of course 11 of those are operated
by the counties
and then we also have service link aging
and disability resource centers and
these are independent providers they are
501 c
3s we have seven contracts and they work
in 13 locations statewide
and they are responsible for referrals
and for things like medicare counseling
and things like that that we'll get into
a little bit further
later on representative rogers has a
question for you
yeah deb you told us what your vacancy
was before
um but what kind of vacancy do you have
with the adult protective services
is that full or do you have vacancies
there
adult protective services is full and
during the hiring freeze that was
prioritized for maintaining keeping that
in place
we needed that safety net especially
during covid so
they are fully staffed and on the
delivery service um
with your providers do you know what
kind of vacancy rate the providers have
or
is that something you're not aware of um
i i don't know if i would refer to it as
a vacancy rate but i would
refer to it as a workforce fulfillment
right
okay and so for example i'm sure that my
colleagues and partners
at the nursing facilities are going to
be very clear about the fact that they
are having difficulty getting staff to
be able to deliver services
just as i think if you spoke with gsil
or other personal care service providers
or home health agencies they too are
having trouble attracting
workforce in the home and community
based setting as well
but you don't have any quantitative
numbers on what how bad it is do you
um i can take a look at that but i think
that
they would definitely have it yeah they
think
about the numbers
so moving forward i mentioned that we
had nine major program areas
and i'm going to go through these pretty
quickly
the first is the choices for
independence waiver and
these are people that are found eligible
for waiver services
and the services include case management
personal care
you can get a mid-level range of care
which is your assisted living facilities
supported housing non-medical
transportation all of these are listed
here
and these are older adults and adults
with disabilities that choose to remain
at home and in their community rather
than getting
nursing facility care and that is an
option that we provide
as a waiver to our state plan services
and it's something that many many many
people choose to do they choose to stay
in their home in their community
the next program area is adult
protective services
which i've explained in some detail
already then we have what's the
administration on aging or title three
programs
and these are the programs that you've
heard a lot about
um during the kovic crisis these are the
home delivered meals
these are family caregiver supports
medicare counseling
adult day services and several
prevention programs that we have
and these are for individuals who are 60
or older
but are not medicaid eligible and these
are individuals that have to demonstrate
a need for
services and are in social and economic
need
then we have what's known as social
services block grant
otherwise known as title 20 services and
again the services
include home delivered meals home health
services adult day service
and these again are for 60 and older and
also adults between 18 and 59 with
chronic illness or physical disability
who are not on medicaid
i think representative while there's a
question
excuse me thank you home delivered meals
does this include the meals on wheels
people that are sort of independently
financed
yes representative weiler this does
include meals on wheels
does the state give them a stipend
uh the state contributes a portion as
well as our federal partners
thank you kathy give another question or
is your hand is still up
you go sorry continue okay
um moving forward we also have the
service uh link resource centers again
uh they serve statewide in various
regions
and they are responsible for information
referral they do
person-centered options counseling they
provide
oversight for the new hampshire family
caregiver program
they do senior medicare patrol which
helps prevent fraud
and make sure that our medicare
beneficiaries are aware
of what their um
benefits are and then we also do direct
veteran directed home and
community-based services as well
through our service link resource
centers it's important to know that
people of all
ages disabilities and income levels can
come through
our service link resource centers as
this is a no wrong door approach
and lastly we have our nursing facility
level of care
and again 71 nursing facilities 11 are
operated by the counties
our approach here is to make sure that
those who need a nursing facility level
of care
and are unable to remain safely at home
or in the community
gain admittance and we partner very
closely with the counties
on assuring that these services are
delivered
um i also think it's important to note
here that this is a
team approach here at dltss the division
of medicaid services
two times per year sets the nursing
facility rates
and also our health facilities
administration and program integrity
also play a role relative to licensing
and during the covid crisis there was an
awful lot of support and movement
forward from all parts of the department
for our nursing facilities
representative edwards has a question
dave
you're done mute
i'm used to leaving it off commute uh
okay so thank you mr chairman
mike my question is on the
nursing facilities uh earlier on we saw
a slide
that showed a tremendous growth rate in
the number of people
85 plus and and so
it just makes me curious to what extent
you have a 10-year plan for the number
of beds we need in a nursing home
and to what extent that 10-year plan is
coordinated and owned at the county
level
and and i asked that because our most
recent administrator
and rockingham did not have a 10-year
plan
and uh and just so it seems to me like
we're falling behind
on capital requests and i'm i'd like you
to
tell me if i'm i'm missing something or
or if we are in fact falling behind
okay so representative edwards that's a
very good question and thank you for
bringing it up
i think what we're doing now is we have
we are meeting on a regular basis once
again with our nursing facilities and
county partners i know that
representative weiler has joined
that committee meeting and i think that
shall be part of the discussion moving
forward um i think during the covid
crisis we are actually looking and i
think
you know the nursing facilities would
definitely be able to speak to you
about this is that we're looking at
potentially a lower census because of
outbreaks and the coveted units had
higher intensity of care and things like
that
all of this will need to be considered
moving forward in cooperation with the
counties
and with the nursing facilities and i
know that we're for example we have a
meeting
this friday the 12th where all some of
this will be discussed and this can be a
partnership moving forward
so follow up if i may um so
so i think what i hear you say is to the
to
in response to my question is there
isn't currently a 10-year plan with a
fixed head bed count that we know that
we should be planning on
but that you anticipate a process to
arrive at one
and i i would like to think in a 10-year
plan we we've sort of moved
beyond pandemic planning
um what i would say is i don't want to
over commit but i think that that has
got to be part of the dialogue we have
with the counties moving forward sir
feel free to continue thanks
so with that i'd like to give henry
lippman an opportunity to walk us
through
nfqa mqip
and proshare which are three acronyms
that have a
deep impact on where we are with our
work with the counties and with the
county share
um thank you deb and thank you for
the opportunity to present again to the
committee um
so the nfqa tax is sort of the beginning
point of
trying to bring um additional monies to
support um
[Music]
nursing facilities and uh um
the the question actually before i start
though just in
where we ended up last time i i had a
trying to recall whether the moratorium
on nursing home beds
um which was have historically been a
legislative
uh action is still in place i
i know if karen if you uh um can
refresh my memory on that or not but i
just believe that it is
but i believe edwards going back
to the 1990s has been a moratorium on
adding
new beds and i think the the demographic
pressures are
are getting um that to be considered
in terms of for long-term planning
because it's been a while since that's
been considered
um but you know the excuse me before you
continue
didn't you just approve new beds out on
the seacoast
um i don't mean you necessarily but the
state
i'm not that project representative
okay i believe represented as a question
so um thank you for educating me that
the legislatures imposed
a bed count moratorium um
do you need anything in hb2 to
empower you to do planning because i
think
planning for beds 10 years out is maybe
different than building them
and it starts with a plan so do you need
anything from us and hb2
to allow you to plan so i guess i would
like to
um work through karen to consult with
the commissioner and
um circle back to you on that if that's
all right
um so in terms of the nfqa tax it's it's
sort of a beginning point
to be able to uh draw additional funds
to fill in the gap between what medicaid
pays
and um the costs uh that
nursing facilities incur and so there is
a
a tax that of five and a half percent
that is applied to
patient service revenues and and that
tax
is then um paid to
the dra it is transferred to the
department
and the department draws down a federal
match typically it's 50 50.
during the pandemic it is
56.2 federal match that extra 6.2
percent
on the federal portion um starting i
believe it was
in the first quarter of the pandemic
the state passed that money directly
back to the nursing facilities didn't
retain any of
that but that tax if you could go to the
next slide please
funds what is the payment which is known
as the
medicaid quality assessment program
payment
and um the uh
this this program has been in place for
for quite a w
uh a long time there's been refinements
to it as
cms has reviewed and refined their
regulations the
most recent refinement happened in last
fiscal year
it didn't change the amount that was um
collected or or paid out it basically
just
made sure that the the tax and the
payment was made by the state before the
the federal match was drawn and so that
had a bit of a timing
impact on nursing facilities but but not
a lot
but it was needed to be addressed in
order to
be current with current regulations
let me stop there if there's any
questions on those two pieces that sort
of come together to
fill in part of the gap now the this
particular payment goes to both
private nursing homes and to the county
nursing facilities
is there this payment timing related to
the pro share payment timing transfers
uh no okay thank you
anybody else have any questions looks
like you're okay hand me to go ahead
okay um if if not
um i think we've kind of covered
both the tax and this this particular
payment and
i think again um to the benefit of the
nursing facilities
the public health emergency to the
extent it
continues as expected those additional
payments
have amounted to about 1.3 million a
quarter
to the nursing facilities those will
continue um to the
uh if the public health emergency runs
the end of
those calendar years as expected um
would
um also mean that the the uh enhanced
federal match would continue to go to
the nursing facilities
um the the next um
slide here talks about pro share one and
pro share two
i know from having been to various
county meetings over the years
um that this is a really important part
when i first came to the department in
2017 there was some
restructuring of pro share one and pro
pro share that had to be done
so that there would not be a reduction
in the amount
of money being able to draw historically
the transaction was generated
first from the state providing money
to the counties and the counties keeping
a portion and then sending
a portion back the feds came around in
2018 and 19
allowed us to restructure it to um
to draw down additional monies but with
the
caveat that we eventually the caveat
that came through that we had to
um have the federal um i mean the
non-federal share
come from the counties itself with
respect to pro share one
and that pro share two counties were
converted to
um what they call a certified public
expenditure
but from a big picture standpoint what
pro shares intended to do
is after you've made the per diem
payment
after you've made the m quip payment is
to fill in the gap
between um in the case of pro share one
what medicare would otherwise pay
and what those payments are so if you
will the process
intended to try to fill in that last bit
of gap
um for proshare 2 it's essentially the
same kind of concept but not that
instance we're comparing
medicaid costs to medicaid payments
and again this the difference that
you're trying to fill in is
the gap between costs and payments
the each year that we do a pro share
transaction we go through a process of
state plan amendments
we're currently in that phase right now
cms has
identified some changes that they want
in the
in the calculation we're still on
negotiating
around those changes
i know a number of counties have
approached us about getting a sense of
kind of where things stand and later
this week we're going to be
sharing what we know of by county
in terms of the the calculations but the
the issues that they've raised in the
current pro share
that they hadn't raised in prior years
is you know i said that the
in both pro share 1 and pro share 2
you're comparing
um cost or payments to what
met what medicaid or medicare would
otherwise pay
and so what they're saying now is with
respect to
what medicare or medicaid pays that in
particular
the there is a portion when medicare
determines what a facility should be
paid that the patient
also contributes and they're saying that
with respect to
um to proshare that the payments
that that patients make towards their
care
that that has to be counted uh towards
what payments the the facilities are
being
credited for receiving historically last
cycle the the pro share payment
was based on what just the state paid
and or what medicare would have
otherwise paid
as a direct payment not not taking into
account
the patient payment they've also um
asked us to um look at um
a different methodology for the upper
payment limit
we've been working um with
cms on looking at some different ways to
compensate for
what um what changes they're looking to
make and
um are continuing to to work on that
again i think
what i can do at this point and what we
intend to do is
um based on where we are in the process
is to share
um with the county nursing facilities
where we stand at the moment and that
we're going to continue to work over the
next
several months to try to improve upon
where um
they're sort of directing us at this
point let me pause there i know
representative you and i have had some
conversations so hopefully this a little
this is ringing true to you
um it's a little bit complicated but i
think if you keep the
simple thing in mind here that this
payment's intended to fill in that last
gap between
either what medicaid paid or what
medicare paid and
um what's going on right now is is
a redefinition of what ethan medicare
medicaid paid from the standpoint of the
feds in terms of looking at what's
matchable
the positive news here i guess in terms
of um
the f enhanced fmap is that with respect
to the pro share one counties that
um assuming the public health emergency
is still in effect which i think it will
be for sure
um when it comes to the june payment
that it won't be 50
that has to be raised it will be the
43.8 percent
so let me stop there that was a lot to
put into that slide
um see if there are questions
anybody else have any questions henry's
been kind enough to answer a lot of mine
previously
i guess you're good to go mr lipman okay
um deb i think that's the last slide
or right um the only thing that i'd just
like to call an attention to before i
advance to uh caseloads is that
um as we go through the accounting units
um
in 2154 and 504
programmatically what we have done is we
have worked with a
nursing facility to repurpose 27 beds
to create a jerry psychiatric unit
and our intent in repurposing these 27
beds is that this will allow us to be
able to create a continuum of care
where we will be able to move people
from new hampshire hospital
into this unit and thereby provide
additional capacity to move people out
of the ed
into new hampshire hospital and this way
we'll make ensure that people are
getting the right level of care and
support
in the jury psychiatric unit that will
be established with the repurposing of
these 27 beds
and we are hoping to have that uh up and
running and
operational at the start of uh the the
upcoming fiscal year
and that is included in 504 in the
atypicals
so just make a note of that so moving
forward
is that what i might have heard about
are you out on the c cones
yep i am i am assuming that is that is
what you are speaking to but
it's a very important capacity build for
a continuum of care
and uh that is noted in 504
i think representative edwards has a
question for you
so i think uh ms sheets may have just
answered it i i was just curious of the
physical location where those 27 beds
will be
um i it's ocean side
that is the nursing facility that we are
partnering with
and that's a i'm sorry i'm unfamiliar so
oceanside is a a private
nursing home and and they are
constructing
actually constructing expanding their
facility to create
physical space for 27 beds and then
they're going to worry about staffing it
um what they are doing is they have the
27 beds there
and are repurposing those 27 beds
and they have brought in on a jerry
spike specialist
and are getting the staffing lined up to
support that approach
and what what town is oceanside
um i believe it is hampton or
northampton wendy can you confirm for
me i know i drove i drive by it
frequently yes it's in hampden
hampton yep
good to go thank you all right so
um next i just wanted to review some
basic uh
case load figures on duplicated um as
you can tell with aps
um we had seen an upward trend with the
exception
of uh 2020. um the case reporting is
down we attribute this to covid
just to be aware that we have done a
tremendous outreach effort
uh to try and get communities neighbors
helping neighbors partnering to be able
to keep
the case reporting up and on
our website you will see a weekly
account we track this regularly to make
sure that we
are getting as much eyes on and as much
uh community collaboration to ensure
that nobody is at risk despite
um kovid and despite the fact that
people have been in their homes and not
as many people
in and out of the homes of the people
that we support in the community
the cfi shows an upward trend and
enrollment trend
which we would expect with or without
covid based on the growing population
here in new hampshire of seniors
nursing facilities you'll see that the
census is down in 2019 from 2019 to 20.
we could uh contribute that to covid all
right
in terms of the fact that there are
outbreaks and the inability to place
people there
and i think that you know as things move
forward
we would be taking a good hard look at
that relative to rate setting
and a number of other factors when you
take a look at our title three and title
programs you will see that um
this is down and i believe the reason
that this is down is because of
primarily workforce
issues in terms of the delivery of these
services
and um when you have issues getting
individuals to deliver those services
it means that you're going to see a
reducing census there
and then for our service link our census
is
is expectedly growing because new
hampshire's population is growing
and we're seeing a growth in everything
from medicare counseling to veterans
programs
and this is to be fully expected
our key accomplishments um i think that
what you'll do is you'll see a trend
throughout this as well as the next two
bureaus
for beas we have worked very very much
so on a state plan on aging
and we continue to work very
collaboratively with the governor state
commission on aging
the idea is to help prepare the state
for this growing population of seniors
and uh to be prepared for 2030
and to be prepared for 2050 and the
governor's state commission on aging has
a leadership position there and the
state plan on aging is housed on the
department's website
and if you would like to look at that
it's easily accessible
the other key accomplishments we have
are specific to covid
19. we have worked very cooperatively
and collaboratively
with our providers in the community
as well as our cms partners in the
submission of an appendix k
which allows us to get federal approval
for greater flexibilities during the
public health emergency
and most importantly we worked with new
hampshire employment security and the
provider community to stand up the
long-term care stabilization program
which provided stipends to ensure that
people stayed
in place in their positions during the
height of the covenant emergency
we have received a tremendous amount of
funding
through our title programs
that we have made numerous contract
amendments to to push out dollars to
help support meals
on wheels adult day services and service
links program
as an example and previously i mentioned
the adult protective services outreach
campaign
for key challenges i i go back to
the information technology it's critical
for us to be able to
conduct our business at a transaction
and operational level
and it's critical for us to be able to
do system transformation moving forward
workforce we continue to struggle with
capacity
in both our nursing facilities and in
home and community based services
and in terms of system transformation
it's very difficult for us to move
system transformation forward
unless we have the the staff
in place and we filled up the vacancy
rates moving forward within the bureau
of elderly and adult services
and this is terribly important because
we need to prepare
and to innovate when it comes to aging
services
i believe that i'm sorry sharon go ahead
thank you very much um so the last uh
box here public health emergency funding
and the services outreach um
do we have a time frame for that
the public health emergency funding has
been coming through
through our federal partners
and as you for example if you were to
look at the gnc
uh agenda you'll see that a lot of them
went through as informational
and we've been pushing that funding out
as we receive it to our providers in the
community
but do we know heard me so do we know
when it ends is there a time frame
uh anything that we have received we
have pushed through in contracting
um as you know uh our federal partners
have put through
um are in the process of putting through
additional relief
uh packages we will need to examine that
and see if there's any further aid that
will be coming our way
so right now it's been a one-time
okay thank you very much president
edwards you have a question
um meals thank you mr chairman um
meals on wheels in manchester uh
i assume that there's a kitchen
somewhere that supports the
cooking and preparation of the meals
puts them into some sort of vehicle
and then drops them off is that
basically the way that works
uh i'm going to ask wendy altman to
speak to that because i am not real
familiar with the
manchester approach and what's going on
there
okay and just just to foreshadow where
i'm going
i in this new new center there's a
kitchen that
seems to be able to produce a lot more
meals than what they actually are
and i'm just wondering if there's a way
to leverage existing resources
i'd like to know where manchester based
meals and wheels
are getting their meals wendy can you
speak to this please
yes so good afternoon um
chair and committee um again my name is
wendy altman
i'm the bureau chief at the bureau of
elderly and adult services
and in relation to your question mr
edwards i am
in manchester there are several
different sites and in the
surrounding area around manchester many
of them
do have kitchens where they either prep
home delivered meals or they actually
cook and prepare the meals so some of
our nutrition providers use
vendors who bring in
prepared food and they heat it and and
prepare it
for delivery or for what we call
congregant meals and the congregant
meals has been
suspended since the public health
emergency but they still utilize the
kitchen and the area and the workers to
to prepare those meals and put them in
the in the
in the warmers that they need um to
go out on the road and deliver the meals
to people's homes
thank you so so we're using vendors in
manchester now
and not state assets we're contracting
out for vendors
correct
i can't hear you there you go you know
the question sharon you all set
i think you're going good to go deb all
right thank you
um so i did take a look at the workload
benchmarks
and i just want to share a little bit
here um
i focused on adult protective services
because it is so terribly
critical to the way that we process and
protect people
so um the workload is that we act
process all accurately completed
registry requests
on a timely basis per rule and as you
know before somebody hires somebody to
bring them into a nursing facility for
example they would need to do the
background check against the registry
so our quality standard is that we
respond within five days to registry
requests 100
of the time and right now with the
exception of a few periods during the
covid
crisis we were hitting that as well as
we could
and we will continue to work towards
that quality standard moving forward
the second one is that adult protective
services
initiates an investigation within 72
hours of a report
um and i just wanted to share that in
state fiscal year 20 our time frame was
at 100
our intent is always to be able to
respond within a hundred percent
um on this one please know that
level one is the highest risk these come
in as a level one or a level two
and if it's a level one we aim to get in
the home within 24 hours
or less moving on that and then the
uh last one is the workload
relative to the level of care
determination process
we look to determine and complete a
level of care determination within 60
days
and right now we are working within a 95
benchmark
our quality standard is to get a 100 of
the level of care determinations
processed within 60 days of
intake um the eligibility
unit and the kovic crisis
made that difficult at times but we are
working towards getting back
up to 100 in terms of our benchmarking
and that is something that we are
constantly looking at
and considering relative to improvement
um so we took a look at the incremental
and decremented
a budget outcome if we were to receive a
five percent increase
we would apply that five percent
increase to
uh cfr waiver rates for the adult day
service program
and home health which could potentially
assist with improving workforce capacity
development and would ensure greater
consumer satisfaction in sports we would
look to hire three additional staff
positions
to one work on cfi waiver administration
and improve customer service for the
eligibility processing i had mentioned
where we're at a 95 percent rate
and we would also use it for grant
management and oversight
and lastly we would look at hiring two
additional
aps staff adult protective services
staff
to improve the intake and registry
processing
because we are beginning to closely bump
up against
what our current staffing can handle and
if i had that five percent i'd be
planning now for it um and
representative wallner has a question
for you yeah i deb i just wondered if
any of these are were in your
prioritized needs
uh they were not in the prioritized
needs but the prioritized needs
clearly indicated the rate increases for
case management
for personal care services and for
homemaker services
thank you could i ask one more question
of course
i wondered what is the what a kind of a
caseload
are your adult protective service um
staff caring wendy do you have that
figure offhand
hi we we'd have to get back to you
that's those are numbers that we're
running
this week typically in the past
on average depending on
the area of the state and the intakes
coming in
um could it could run between
10 to 10 to 20 cases per worker
thank you and it varies again by
area of the state based on where i'm
from
okay um
if the budget were decreased um
we would have to reduce non-medicaid
billable services
and we would run into a risk of
non-compliance for grant waiver and
other federal funding
which could result in a loss of medicaid
federal funds or
recruitment moving forward
and with that i'm going to hand it over
to karen rounds
great thank you dad i'm going to go
ahead
and
take over sharing okay um so
this budget as you can see here is quite
a large budget
most of it um being related
to a nursing home
and accounting unit 2152 which we will
get to in just a moment
so that's most of what you are seeing
there
and then we can move right into the
accounting units for this bureau
which start on page 997 with accounting
unit
92.50
okay and accounting unit 9250
is adult protective service worker apsw
for short operations
this is where the employees
who are adult protective service workers
uh would be
so
okay not hearing
any questions so the next one is 78.72
the admin on aging which is at the
bottom of page 998
it goes on to 999.
this is where the meals on wheels
contracts are
what is the governor's it's not a lot of
money but it's a big jump in um
line is that
40 indirect costs
so um that i believe that i've provided
the information from department of
administrative services
on how indirect costs are calculated
okay we don't we don't control what that
line
ends up being is that true of all your
accounts sometimes they're in there and
sometimes they're not
because it's right it's true of line 40
line 41. no no i
understand that it's two of those lines
what i meant was some
accounts have indirect class some
accounts don't sometimes have
yes that is true and i don't i don't
remember the formula off the top of my
head as to why some of them have them
and some of them don't
okay it's based on a formula i'm sure
44 well class all of the personnel
class lines plus 40 41 and 42 are all
um determined by administrative services
okay
did someone else have a question there i
thought it's a game but i guess not
watch out okay
the next accounting unit is 8917 which
is health promotion
contract this is a federal grant
representative raised her hand ah go
ahead website
i'm sorry it's further on my question
okay
all right the next one is 9255 which is
social
social services block grant also known
as ssbg
if i can continue all right the next one
is
8925 which is medicaid services grants
ship
i'd say you can probably continue okay
the next accounting unit
is no wrong door uh which is a grant
that
um is an all likelihood ending but we
have budgeted a dollar just in case that
grant does end up coming forward
and as i've mentioned those should all
be federal dollars when we do that
and it is yes um the next one
is 3317 admin on aging services grant
sm e
i don't see any hands okay
uh the next one 89 20 money follows the
person this is also a grant
that has uh pretty much ended but
has the potential of continuing forward
that's the
two dollars there okay uh
90 10 is volunteer activities
just like curiosity what is that
that is our senior companion program
okay so the volunteers obviously they're
not getting paid
just to run it is that it's a volunteer
program
where um we work collaboratively
with the counties belknap grafton
hillsborough merrimack stratford and
sullivan
and it's a state federal private
partnership where we're
where delnap is the federally designated
contractor
and we put in a certain percentage of
money so that we can keep that program
going
okay thanks
go ahead so i i didn't hear an answer
there
what what what is the money in that line
item actually paying for
is it paying for personnel is it paying
for specialty gifts for vet
for volunteers wendy can you explain the
state share
please yeah um the contract that we have
with belnet merrimack cap
with these funds pays
primarily for mileage reimbursement
for those senior companion volunteers to
travel to
individuals homes to perform the
services
okay the next accounting is 95.65 which
is service link
all right the next accounting unit is 89
18.
that's new hampshire foster grandparents
that program
was put into the budget last biennium
and is uh i believe suspended in hb2
this biennium for 22-23 i'm sorry
okay
it looks like representative olner might
be trying to raise their hand i'm not
sure
sorry go ahead and thank you
um did the department request funding
for this program
no so it was not even requested of the
governor
correct it was not in the agency budget
thank you
excuse me uh karen i think sharon has a
question for you okay
i think you muted sean
sorry um so in 95 65
of the 74 and 102
are sort of inverted what why is that
say that again which class line are you
looking at 74
and 102. oh yep
that's the so i think i've talked about
it a little bit we're moving
um con contracts that are for sub
recipients
um from class 102 and to 74 to better
track them
for the single audit okay thank you
you're welcome
all right the next accounting unit is
8915 which is congregate housing
this is very similar to the program i
just talked about here the new hampshire
foster grandparents
we did not implement the program and the
agency did not request
uh funds for it for 22 23.
let's go ahead mention
no karen just answered my question thank
you
you're welcome i thought you might ask
again so
your mind reader sharon only
occasionally it's a hard skill to use
um the next accounting unit is 8943
which is alzheimer's and
related disorders
okay continuing down
uh the next accounting unit is uh 21.52
this is the accounting unit where uh the
nursing home payments
and the um the cfi
waiver are paid out of this is also
where
the county participation is which is
also known as the county cap
uh so what i i'm just going to preempt i
know some of the questions that i'm
going to get and talk about it a little
bit more um so one of the things that
you're going to see here
or that you do see here is that the
general funds are budgeted
at 5 million dollars for 22 and 23.
the reason for that is that the statute
the statute for county cap requires that
the
state uh provide a five million dollar
credit
to counties so that's what we have
budgeted which is the statutory
requirement of the five million
dollar credit to counties there has been
a a history
of additional general funds being added
here however they
would not be considered a credit under
statute they were just additional
general funds that reduced
the county contribution
you'll also notice that the overall
budget is
up about
what 15 million dollars from 21 to 22
um and then it's even funded in 23. uh
and i think deb spoke to some of that
reason but she
she can also um talk about it more if
need be
there is the 3.1 percent rate increase
that happened in one one of um 20 and
then again on one one of 21
and of course that rate increase would
not be would only be reflected in fiscal
year 21 for part of the year
and i wouldn't even say half of the year
because payments don't happen
immediately for that month um
so that is part of that increase
additionally there are some rate
increases which i know deb to talk about
built in
for cfi um on the the four cfi lines
there
um so that is also part of that increase
that you're seeing there so i'll stop
there
i'm sure there are some additional
questions so karen one of the questions
i got related to that
everything you just said made sense but
it you didn't mention the fact that
the bad occupancy rates are down and i'm
not anticipated to jump
at least as fine as far as i understand
back up to where they were pre-covered
for a while
did you account for that or can you
account for that in those in the total
number
deb can you talk about that a little bit
i know there's a couple of factors like
the cost report that we use already
um i'm actually going to let henry speak
to that because he's actually spoken to
the
uh counties about that i think henry
actually had to jump
so okay alrighty um
what happens is when we when we
determine the rates
there's a lag on when the rates are um
on when the occupancy rate is calculated
in there so for the time being we are
good but moving forward
the census is going to have to be taken
into consideration and it will be lower
and we need to take a look at that
and um i know that henry has been
talking uh
to the counties about that and has been
a point of dialogue and will be again
most likely as part of friday's meeting
perhaps
okay representative walnut
yes so karen in this proposed
budget for 2223 the governor's budget
there are no rate increases on for any
of these
any of these lines is that correct no so
there are rate increases
for um the cfi lines which
uh deb i believe that's 505 506 and 529.
okay so representative walner in line
home support waiver services that is
where you will find the case management
rate increase and the personal care
services rate increase
and how much are those step okay for
case management you will see
a total fund increase of 2956
nine zero and for personal care
four six six two one zero
two and five can you tell me what
percentage they are
in terms of
like how much how what percentage will
the rate be
increasing um i can tell you that
i can give you the amount i don't know
the percentage offhand unless wendy does
but with personal care
3.1 percent brought it to 489
and we increased it to 562 which puts it
in parity with the state plan
and for the homemaker the 3.1 percent
brought it to 509 and we increased it to
using a cost-based methodology for this
service
okay so those two services case
management
and personal care thank you and in five
um 529 is the homemaker
oh thank you okay 529 is homie thank you
all right and homemaker is 84 thousand
four hundred and ninety two
okay great thank you representative
weiler
thank you i thought i heard you say like
back with service link that it was not
in the agency budget
it's not in the governor's budget yet we
see a couple million dollars
in this um this budget document are
there other
agencies or other areas in this budget
document that were not
included in the governor's budget or
in the agency budget yet are still in
this
budget we look at
i don't i don't know that i understand
the question
when i said that there was something not
in the agency or the governor's budget
it was new hampshire foster grandparents
which is
not showing you know not budgeted
anything in 2223
and maybe maybe i missed her i think i
was looking at service link when i heard
that
oh okay yeah no that's referring to the
foster grandparent
yes i was okay so i guess there
that's why it's zeroed out all right so
yes
that was my curiosity was looking at
service lincoln
thinking it wasn't funded and yet it was
thank you you're welcome
looks like you might be good to go again
that wasn't too bad was it
no none of it's too bad uh
the next one is 29.29 21.54
which is nursing services this is not
funded with county funds this is
50 50 general funds 50
federal funds
so just comparing to
the last well the current biennium it
looks like it went down
it did so uh part of what's going on
here um
so the oh the other thing that i should
have mentioned going back to 2152
you've just pointed out what i forgot to
talk about just
eight atypicals um
which are uh nursing home residents
uh that require some kind of specialized
level of care like deb was talking about
earlier with the new beds on the
seacoast
those are considered atypical beds um
during the legislative session in 20 and
and i will take full responsibility for
not fully understanding the budget at
that time
um i had been no no excuse but i'd only
been with the department about a year
and so this was an area that i was still
definitely learning
and during the legislative phase 2152
was
changed and we moved to the atypicals
to 2154 and we shouldn't have
um they are part of the
uh statute of what the counties are
responsible for
paying um and so they should not have
been moved
so these expenses actually um
this class 504 and fiscally it took me a
year to figure out that i messed that up
and so fiscal year 21 um we did not
we will not expend any of this 3.5
million it will be paid out of 21.52
and going forward we have budgeted it in
21.52
so that's the half that was
reduced in this coming biennium is that
what you're saying
um yes that's what was reduced that was
what was removed that classline 504.
so um and fiscal year 20 the actuals
were about 7.6 million
so this increase here the 204 to 221
about seven or eight million of that is
that atypicals
so your mother are you on the line 505
in the
in both
uh 504 is in both 505 is not
okay 504 is a nursing home that's where
the typicals would be in
yes okay and that's the one that we
moved
that's when you add it back into yes
that's the one we put back into 2152
which is where it has historically been
um like i said it was i completely owned
that that
was a mistake so yeah that's i'm not
worried about the mistake
um so so that accounts are part of the
increase as well
yes lines there budget number line 504
and 21.52 yes
and what we can do um uh created a nice
little chart of
what the increases are attributed to
here um
on 2152 and we can provide that to the
committee we have already provided it to
the counties
okay that'd be great so then does
atypical come out of 2154
going forward um so going forward
atypicals will be in 2152.
okay okay so that accounts are part of
the
product and then the next year the next
biennium
yep editing yes okay
yes just just so you know folks have
told me that atypicals in both anyway so
apparently it didn't do too much damage
or
moving it around they all figured it out
i think i think we
figured it out hopefully i know jane
represented walmart
yeah so um i just want to go through the
numbers just a little bit so
uh under 2152
um five 504 nursing home payments
the number on that that line is 221
million
and what you're saying is about
10 million of that is from
2154. seven or eight million yes
yes okay but i i'm i'm just basing that
based on actuals from 2154.
we'll get you what was actually budgeted
okay
so we'll see uh we'll see how that yeah
now that line went how line 504
went up and fivo and down here
um in 2154
the line went down okay yes okay
thank you you're welcome
any other questions on 2154
okay the next accounting unit is 2157
which is
mquip payments which uh was one of the
payments that henry spoke about earlier
and like i said he he is no longer able
to join us this afternoon so
if there are questions we may need to
just follow up
so the agency income that's the tax is
that correct
that's correct and then it gets matched
by the feds yes
okay and the nursing homes are paying
the tax on their
occupancy on their revenue yeah net
patient service revenue
okay so i'm a revenue source of sound
yes okay yes
uh and representative wallner you have
another question or
no i'm sorry put my hand down sorry
no problem i think you can go on karen
honestly in your hands
all right the next one is uh 2161
which is pro share payments um you can
see that we've essentially level funded
this
as henry spoke about uh we
go back to cms every year and amend the
state plan
and so we typically come to fiscal
committee every year
and change the budget as well so can you
begin to explain the relationship
between the numbers
that are here and the numbers of the
counties see
um like why
well so for instance over the last few
years and this is what one of the things
that
henry's been negotiating with the change
is this
sort of the well the amount the amount
of money is going to come down
but so the monies come into the county
they go to the state and get doubled and
then half well traditionally half comes
back that that that part's going away
i'm just wondering is is this the part
that goes
up to the county and then gets doubled
or is this the double
not well you know what's the you know
what i'm trying to ask
i do and i forget because
every year i have to relearn exactly how
it goes through the accounting system
how pro share one and pro share two go
through because it's two different ways
right so if you want what i can do um
is uh we could
we could walk you through that sometime
i would need athena gagnon as well um
because she's been doing it a couple
more years than jane and i have
okay i'd love to understand the
relationship between what i see in the
in the states and what happens in the
county level yes
we can do that we can set something up
thank you
anybody else i guess not
okay uh 2164 is cfi waiver program
eligibility
this is where uh staff are
and the move from 102 to 74 here is is
the same as
i've spoken about earlier
okay oh one or two one four
this piece right
right the next one is 2165 which is
civil monetary penalties
which is the last accounting unit in
this bureau
what was that number uh
i got it okay okay
this is actually uh
100 federal funds it looks like the
accounting unit might have closed
incorrectly for
20 so the actuals look a little funny
there um
the general fund should not be there
that that i'm not sure exactly what
happened there
a mistake that's actually kind of
important to me
all right so i'm going to go ahead and
stop sharing and turn things back over
to deb to cover the next bureau
thank you
so
so i'm beginning on slide number 33
and i'm going to ask kevin to bring in
jen doyd who is the business manager
within dltss
and sandy hunt who is the bureau chief
for bds
and d turney who is the bureau chief for
family
centered services and they'll be joining
me for the presentation
as we walk through this today
okay they're coming over now thank you
kevin
oops
sorry just trying to catch up there
alrighty
so um to begin with the bureau of
developmental services serves as the
state's designated agency
and we are responsible for administering
the developmental
disability um acquired brain disorder
and in-home supports waivers and
what we do is we work very hard to
ensure that the right safety and
interdependence of the individuals that
we support
are respected and that we prevent abuse
neglect or exploitation
and what we do is we work with a
comprehensive community based service
delivery system
our partners for the majority of our
work are the area agencies and they are
in 10
regions throughout the state of new
hampshire we also work very
collaboratively with the bureau of
family centered services for the
administration of the early supports and
services programs which is the early
intervention for the children between
the ages of zero to three
and we provide oversight for the wait
list management
for the dd wait list which i'm sure most
of you are familiar with
so the bureau of developmental services
has 23 staff
and we have 12 state contracts 10 of the
state contracts are with the area
agencies
one is with the institute new hampshire
institute on disability which is with
university of new hampshire and then the
final
contract is with the brain injury
association
and again what we do is we work on the
administration
of the three 1915 c waivers
for acquired brain disorder
developmental disabilities and then
in-home supports which is for the
children
our ten regional area agencies are
designated by 171a
to provide these services they do a
tremendous job in heavy lifting for the
financial management and monitoring and
the program
and they work directly with the bureau
on evaluation
and quality assurance and they are
responsible for
ensuring that every individual that's
found eligible for waiver services
receives their services and they are
responsible for
ensuring for service coordination
personal care service delivery
in-home support specialty services
independent living
and they do independent vendor contracts
as needed in regards to this
so again um we count on a regional
system of 10 non-profit 501 c 501c3s
these are the area
agencies they are designated per
rsa 171a and hem 505.
the area agencies are responsible for
leadership
in planning providing and overseeing the
services in their communities
and each agency has attachment areas of
towns that they support and serve
each area agency exercises their own
local control they're governed by a
local board of directors
and one-third of the board membership
must be recipients of bds
services so this is a very very solid
system that has been in place for well
over 30 years
and it continues to evolve as the needs
of the people
that we serve evolve as well as the
complexity of the types of services we
provide
evolve the area
agencies work directly with providers
for services
through a subcontractor service
provision
the area agencies work with the provider
organizations to deliver the home and
community-based care
and there are approximately 70 private
providers
throughout the state that work with the
area agency
system to deliver services so this is a
public private
partnership with local nonprofit area
agencies
the services are community-based and
it's important to note
that new hampshire is under a corrective
action plan for the three waivers with
the center for medicare and medicaid
services
and what we discovered in our waiver
renewal
for the dd waiver is that
we were in violation of conflict of
interest regarding the provision of case
management
and essentially cms frowns upon
the agencies delivering case management
as well as the services
at a systemic level so we were able to
work with cms
to provide that our area agencies can
provide
service coordination and case management
at um not
at the individual level but they are
able to
at the systemic level and we have been
working with the area
agencies and a stakeholder group um to
evolve
that corrective action plan and we have
had to request an extension due to covid
to come into full compliance for that
plan by july 1
2023 if you want to learn more about
corrective action plan it's posted on
the dhhs
website and explains this in greater
detail
but the state is moving forward with the
area agencies and the provider community
to come into compliance by july 1
2023 and this also includes for direct
bill
and direct pay of services deb could you
send
kevin the link to that absolutely
so i wanted to talk a little bit about
the services that are provided
um for the developmental disability
waiver
what we do is as somebody exits the
school system or is new to the state of
new hampshire what we do is we work with
them
to determine what their level of care
need is
and then what we do is we arrange
services through the area agencies and
we deliver
the services to them and hem 503 defines
the eligibility
for the developmental disability and
this is
the way that things have been working
under a single comprehensive dd waiver
for years
the next service is acquired brain
disorder and this is for an individual
that has a brain injury
and would require lifelong supports and
what we do
is we provide the supports in the home
in the community setting
versus in an institutional setting and
hem 22 522 defines eligibility
and that's clearly outlined in rule then
we have what's known as the in-home
supports waiver
and these are personal care services for
children living at home with their
families
and the eligibility uh for these
services are up through the age of 21
and are defined in
hem 524 and
the final area that we provide support
for
is for individual that require
individuals that require 24
services in a secure setting and are
known as
a 171 b's and these are defined our agm
171b
now our forensic services are currently
delivered
through our developmental services
designated receiving facility
which is located up in laconia on the
old
laconia state school property and
in this budget cycle what we are doing
is we are transitioning these services
from the on-site facility at the laconia
state school
and we are transitioning this to a more
community-based approach and we are
working with a vendor
right now a provider right now to be
able to deliver those services
effective july 1 under contract
so what you will see as karen goes
through the accounting units
is you will see that all 17 positions
for this facility have been unfunded
and that we have a contract line item
for these services moving forward
representing norton has a question
thought we had the laconia school was
empty sorry
uh representative weiler um very good
question the laconia state school
is empty the property still houses
a designated receiving facility that is
operated by the bureau of developmental
services
that designated receiving facility that
just so
happens to be on the property of the old
laconia state school
we are phasing out and transitioning
those services
to a more homey community based setting
but still meets the secure requirements
per 171
b and we are going to be providing those
services under a contract versus through
the state moving forward
so how much space are you using and how
many people are employed there
um over the past few years the census
has dwindled and at this point in time
we are looking at potentially contact
contracting for between two
to three beds moving forward
okay thank you i'd also like to advise
the members that
we are working um very closely with the
staff
at the designated receiving facility
that are state employees
to ensure that they have opportunities
for employment elsewhere within the
state
because a lot of their skill sets
translate very well to new hampshire
hospital
to glencliff or even to our corrections
system
moving forward and we have been
partnering
with them to determine the best approach
on ensuring that they maintain and stay
in state service and they're giving full
opportunities to apply for positions
and of course as we
contract with a vendor a vendor may very
well be interested
in picking up some of the staff there as
well so this is
very much been a part of our approach to
the winding down of this facility
thank you very much mr chair um so i
thought the property
up there by the laconia state school is
being sold
is that one of the reasons you're moving
or is it
totally just a program planning
uh programmatically we've seen the
census go down and we see an opportunity
to develop this as part of a continuum
of care
all right where this is just another
level of care that we want to provide
for
and we believe that we can do so um in
a by transitioning off of that property
right thank you
thank you dad carry on okay
so i wanted to talk a little bit about
the developmental disability or dd wait
list
and i would like to start by reminding
um
folks that per 171 a1a
that the legislature is required to
appropriate sufficient funding to meet
weightless costs
and that this is part of statute
and i wanted to explain a little bit
about how we manage the developmental
disability waitlist which also
is outlined in part of our authority
so who is typically waiting for services
we have
um students who are exiting the school
system which we refer to as
a's then we have people who have never
accessed services before
but are in need of services and these
are what we refer to as bees
and then we have individuals who
currently have services but require
additional services
and these are what we refer to as c's
it's hard to anticipate a b
alright because these are individuals
that may
move with a family member into the state
or
we have even still to this day have
families who have
um kept their loved one at home with
them
and they were concerned about their
individual being put in an institution
so they have never come forward looking
for supports or services and
if a parent passes away a sibling or
another loved one
will contact the state to pray to work
with us to get a provision for services
so that describes what it be is um for
the c's
these are people who are typically
living with their families
and due to a change in circumstance they
require a change in services
so we might have a
79 year old parent who might
have medical complexity and have to
themselves go into a nursing facility
and we need to
make arrangements to increase the
services for the child that they have
been living with and they
may look to go into an enhanced family
care
approach or into a residential group
home for example
right now has a question
yeah sean
you're muted
sorry i didn't even know now the
question my hand was still raised
oh i'm sorry i'll try to write that
all right and then for seas we also have
people who may not live with their
families but
they have changes and they require
additional services so for example
we may have somebody who uh is on the
autism spectrum
and is managing to live independently
with supports and services but perhaps
they have had
some behavioral issues that occur and
that requires an increase in the
services
so what we try and do is we work with
providing for those services based on
the level of care
so i wanted to review where we are at
this oops
oops i lost my share let me bring it
back again
while you bringing that back can you
when you when we get to the accounts can
you
let us know where the wait list appears
in the
accounts absolutely
let me just bring this back
are you able to see that now
yes okay
around 41 if you yep
thank you
here we go my apologies no problem
right so for uh this uh biennium
uh we were able to serve a thousand
individuals
in terms of funding them we have 455 a's
and b's that we funded with the original
budget appropriation
we have 494 c's
that we assisted with the original
budget appropriation
and then we funded an additional 51 c's
with funds due to vacancy dollars um
oftentimes uh what will happen is some
unfortunately
somebody will pass away are um something
to that effect and what we try and do
is we we we utilize those dollars to
affect uh bringing others into services
so right now there are zero people
waiting for services
this biennium and um i think it's
important to talk
a little bit about some of the
issues that we've encountered due to
covin
in december and january we had
uh 46 people who were diagnosed covid
positive
in the developmental services system and
that has an impact on the ability to
start services
and also for us to be very agile in the
way that we serve those
individuals so with the kovid crisis
we have had to um we've run into issues
with getting workforce
uh some families have indicated that
they did not want people
in their homes serving people and
um we've also had the consideration of
the cratchit mountain closure
during the clovic crisis cratchit
mountain determined that they no longer
would be providing
residential services to individuals so
we had to work very hard and
collaboratively with the area agency
system
to find to build programs out for 26
people
all right in addition to being able to
support people who were bringing into
services off of the wait list
so beginning in the third quarter of
state fiscal year 20
we started to see not as many starts
at the level that we typically do and
that can clearly be attributed to the
covid crisis
and i wanted to make sure that everyone
was situationally aware
that that has impacted the spend rate
for our waiver services our dd waiver
services in particular
and i just wanted to make everyone aware
of that
so for the acquired brain disorder
waiver we've brought
in 33 individuals served
and for in-home supports we've brought
on an additional 85
individuals served and once again there
are zero people waiting for services
this is a copy of the trending
for the for quite a long period of time
all right i believe it begins in 09 and
now goes to 20.
this is something that uh hhs oversight
uh takes a look at on a quarterly basis
and this is also part of the
department's dashboard
and as you can clearly see as of 12 30
there are zero people waiting for
services
so moving forward and building out
the uh budget for the developmental
services system
and for bds we are anticipating
that at a minimum of 200 uh 226
uh dd individuals will need services
this represents the students known to
bds and the area
agencies who are exiting the school
system
during the fiscal year in 22 and
what we do is we take a look at the
historic trend
on individuals new to the system who may
require services
and in sfy 23 we anticipate that a
minimum
of 198 dd individuals will need services
did i ask you a question there is that
an unusually large
number no it is not that's sort of
normal for buying a name
yes people ever go off services other
than
when they pass away obviously um
i think it's important to understand
that if you are diagnosed with a
developmental disability or an
intellectual disability the assistance
you need with daily living
either remains the same or can
get more complicated as you age all
right
um but this is a lifelong uh
support service system and it is
something that we
take very seriously here in the state of
new hampshire to
ensure that people get the services that
they need and it's a very cost
effective model because the majority of
people are served
in the home and the community right so i
was asking the context of that
right now i said the total 1000
individuals correct
or is that a separate was that a
separate group of people you were
talking about
back on slide 41 that includes c's as
well
those are enhancements as well okay
but but nonetheless i guess my questions
about it is that
one thousand or less individuals are
there now
and you're talking about adding another
400 i'm just wondering roughly that
if that many come come in every two
years i would expect the number
to be much higher total leveling much
higher um
the a's and b's are generally in the
ballpark they can vary a little bit from
year to year
with the c's it can it can vary based on
where somebody is in terms of
uh needing additional supports and
services okay
thanks and again it's a very
individualized service system with
individualized service plans that are
person centered
so in terms of comp accomplishments um
for bds uh we are in the process right
now of working our way through waiver
renewals
and we just received approval for the
in-home supports waiver renewal with our
partner
cms and we are currently working on
submitting the developmental disability
waiver for renewal
um just as with beas we are working very
proactively
with the area agencies in the provider
community
to provide flexibilities in the way they
deliver services
and just as with beas we took a very
proactive
high-profile road role with our partners
at new hampshire employment security
to implement the long-term care
stabilization program that have the
stipends for individuals
to continue to work in the field with
covid and
as i've mentioned before we also have
the corrective action plan with cms that
we have made progress
on and have received uh approvals
for an extension date until july 23.
we also have been working on a federal
requirement to
ensure that we are in compliance with
settings requirements
and our compliance uh for our for our
system
here and for the state of new hampshire
for the homes is currently at 98 percent
and we expect to meet the compliance
requirements uh that are
required by federal rule 42 cfr 441
which is outlined here
we have also put in a significant amount
of effort of working with
um the educational system and the area
agencies to collaborate on transition
planning for individuals who are exiting
the school system
and into adult services it's very
important that those
efforts be done collaboratively so that
we can do good
first projections on needs all right
for our dd waitlist planning and more
importantly to ensure
that we have an understanding of the
individuals that will be exiting and
making sure that we have the services
clearly planned and outlined and ready
to go and have been able to rfp and get
the services moving forward
wait list management we continue to work
wholeheartedly
with our area agency system to continue
to fund and start services but again
the agencies have experienced slower
starts due to covid19
and that's something that we continue to
take a look at
very actively with the agency system
and then of course we continue to look
at system capacity
this past year we did a lot of work with
system capacity builds for
the cratchit mountain residential
program that i mentioned previously
so some of the key challenges for the
bureau of developmental services
as i spoke to earlier is information
technology
specifically the ability to effectuate
system builds for direct billing
electronic visit verification
and the bds it remediation
another key challenge which i spoke to
previously that speaks to the a
m recommendation is the need to build
capacity for intensive treatment
services
and make that part of the continuum of
care
we continue to work on compliance and
operations
so that we can come into uh compliance
with our corrective action plan by 23.
that's one specific
example of a very big lift but we
continue to need to work on
ensuring that our waivers are renewed
and that we're doing appropriate
reporting
for financial reporting and quality
reporting relative to the waivers
and lastly i just will speak briefly to
the bureau of family centered services
in our budget the bureau of family
centered services and bds
are both in the same budget and the same
listing of accounting units
however the bureau of family centered
services works very collaboratively with
the bureau of developmental services
and the bureau of family center services
is responsible for
serving as the state's title five agency
for children and youth with special
health care needs and these are people
with
these are children with complex medical
conditions they also provide for family
support
and the early supports and services
program
they are responsible for the contract
management
and grant oversight for some of the
areas that i mentioned previously
the bureau of family centered services
employs 18 people
and as i pointed out they were the
hardest hit with a 41
nearly 41 vacancy rate they are in the
process
of doing a lot of hiring and onboarding
right now
they are responsible for ensuring that
we meet all of our federal grant
requirements for the funding entities
that i mentioned at the very beginning
of the presentation
with dltss and they are responsible for
working and ensuring that we are
complying with state federal statutes
and regulations
they also work very closely with the
state family support councils
and the council for youth and chronic
conditions to get advice
as to how the program should be
administered and to get
input on how we move things forward
systemically
if there are any systemic issues that
need to be addressed
and these are very important partners as
we develop
programs and administer programs
the bureau of family centered services
works with community-based agencies
they administer 22 contracts
with 14 program sites statewide
and you will see a listing here of the
programs that they
administer at the bottom here under the
community-based agencies they do child
development clinics
which is called watch me grow
coordination they are responsible for
nutrition feeding swallowing and there
are a series of other programs that they
administer through these contracts
with the express purpose of assisting
children that have complex medical needs
or are being an early intervention
to keep them passed between the ages of
zero and three to enter the school
system at the developmentally
appropriate level
the bfcs programs again they fall under
three primary buckets
and that's the system of care for
children with special health care needs
and you can see here that the
eligibility is clearly defined under hem
and these are funded with title title 5
grants which were mentioned very early
on they also are responsible for
providing family support
and they administer the partners in
health program
as well as this is covered under hem 523
and the funding levels for this
are through the area agency systems as
well as through general state funds
they are also responsible for fairly
centered early supports and services
which speaks to the part c
early intervention services
the bfcs key accomplishments again
covid19
i cannot express enough the amount of
effort that's gone in on the part
of the bureaus working with the
community-based
providers and organizations to assure
that people get the services they need
in a safe manner during cobit
and the ability to utilize telehealth
and remote services has been extremely
important
it is something that we are looking to
implement moving forward
we also have just completed our title v
grant application and compliance
which means that we just completed a
five-year needs assessment and we did
this during the covid
emergency and we did this poorly staffed
during that time period
bfcs has also worked with the managed
care organizations
to ensure that they understand the types
of children that we are supporting
the needs of their families and so that
we get a better cooperation and
collaborative approach with the mcos for
supporting these individuals
in terms of key challenges technology
once again the fcs uses in some cases
unsupported data systems to manage case
records and for program implementation
we have workforce issues relative to
nursing respite and pediatric specialty
provider shortages
that are a challenge for the people we
serve and for their families
and again we had a 41 staff vacancy rate
that we are working very hard now to
correct
in terms of um the unduplicated numbers
and for people that we serve and support
i wanted to call your attention to a
couple of items
on this uh table here um
first of all under bfcs you're going to
note that
in sfy 15 the numbers were 4
310 and now in sfy
20 they're 3 3 244.
um that's there's two contributing yes
i was our northern guidance thank you
thank you
deb you're doing a great job um could
you talk a little bit
more about the hiring freeze and what
the status of that is
and where we think we are within
and if it'll end or i mean 41
is pretty traumatic it is it is
terribly traumatic and um the good news
is that the hiring freeze is over
and we immediately were prioritized for
posting our positions
and in on my supervisory with dee dunn
today who is the bureau
chief we are well on our way
to filling those positions and starting
the onboarding process
we've been fortunate that we've been
able to fast-track this because there is
an
understanding for the for the vacancy
rate in this bureau
i guess you're good to go
so um i wanted to talk a little bit
about the differential between 15
and 20 in the bfcs line here
in 2015 we determined that we had a
duplication
in count efforts for our partners in
health in our area
agencies and we have been working
towards correcting that over a three
year period
and what happens is as children age out
that correction is made and people are
not getting a duplication and services
another contributing factor to this is
that
the lack of pediatric specialists
for for example for for the nutrition
and swallowing clinics
makes it difficult to fulfill the
services at the levels we were before
because the children are complex
so that explains why we are looking at
lower accounts in sfy
20. i'd also like to call your attention
to fc ess which is our early supports
and services
in state fiscal year 19 it was 5038
and in sfy 20 it's 4595.
our early supports and services programs
are delivered in the homes of
individuals
and during the covid crisis
many families did not want individuals
in their homes delivering those services
so
because of covid we saw the census
numbers go down
for this budget cycle i have
put in for our fcess services to
come in at the previous amount the sfy19
amount because at that point in time we
had been consumed
continuously trending upwards slightly
and i do believe that this is an anomaly
that is specific to covid
and i just wanted to call your attention
to that
in terms of workload benchmarks
right now we have uh our requirements
in terms of oversight of the waivers
that we have to do what's known as a 372
report which is a financial report
against our waivers
and we need to compare the approved
waiver services to the costs realized
for services and costs
and we are responsible for doing this on
time
on a yearly basis and it's an
expectation that this is done 100
on time and accurate and that is a key
bench load uh benchmark and workload
that we work towards
prior authorization processing um prior
authorizations for emergent services are
processed
timely at a hundred percent however we
have been short staffed in our prior
authorization unit
for over three years the good news is
with the hiring freeze being lifted we
have started the hiring process to be
fully staffed again
so we do have some authorization syses
and hearsts which
are essentially evaluations or
assessments
these are completed after the 45-day
requirement due and some of them
are extremely tardy right now so our
objective in terms of prior
authorization processing is to approve
100 percent of prior authorizations
within 45 days of receipt and services
beginning
and then the other thing we do is we
work very hard to maintain the stability
of our area agency system
and that we know that we are operating
with our area
agencies with integrity so what we do
is every two years we do a redesignation
of our area agencies and we review
governance
financial management contractual and
regulatory requirements
and client and family satisfaction this
is outlined for
rsa 171 a as well as in
hem 505 so every two years
um for so every year two agencies
undergo this review
and the bds staff works to do this on
time
and with the consideration that it is
due because it is very very important
um what i would what we would do with
the bureau of developmental services and
bfcs
in terms of incremental and decremented
outcomes
um if we were given a five percent
uh increase we would we would build
intensive treatment services capacity
in state to drive down the cost per
client and enhance positive outcomes for
community inclusion
and what we would do as part of that is
we would
hire up some
two additional staff to help provide
oversight for that build
and we would look at starting up
residential housing and staffing
education and specialty hiring
with those dollars in addition we would
hire one staff
to provide oversight for the corrective
action plan implementation and oversight
if our budget was cut we would
that would continue to necessitate
continued outplacement
of some of our people that we serve
which we do not like to send
the people that we serve out of state
and we would
be unable to potentially serve people
off of the developmental disability wait
list
and in the end if we did not serve
people off of the dt wait list and we
ran a wait list
those individuals would cost more in the
long run
because the gains that they had made
through the school system
would be lost because they would be at
home without the services that they need
and their families would be responsible
for caring for them and
maintaining them and with that
i will hand it over to karen unless
there are questions
great okay so
uh just doing a time check chair i know
you said you wanted to try to wrap up by
30. it looks like you still have a
quorum
we just have these group of accounting
units left do we want to try to get
through them absolutely care as long as
you're willing
oh yes that would be great i think it'd
be great to not have to bring the group
back for a half an hour tomorrow
i was actually wondering who you were
talking to at first then i really did
i believe you were the acting chair at
the moment good point
thank you so um just going quickly
through this 1819 to 2021 the biggest
jump here
is uh the governor's budget in 2021
essentially eliminate the wait list and
as you can see from our current numbers
the dev reviewed
we do not have a wait list so it um did
what it was intended to
so jumping right into the accounting
units the first one is 7100
which is developmental services here on
page 1132
uh chair you asked to point out when we
get to the accounting unit that had the
developmental disabilities wait list it
is
included in this accounting unit uh
historically
before my time so at least three
bienniums ago waitlist funds were in a
separate class line or a separate
accounting unit and it actually created
more problems than it solved
so it is one accounting unit um that has
all of the potential dollars to serve
the developmental disability
community okay so basically between the
contracts the program services and the
payment providers is your
is the funding the 102 and 502 i'm on
the right line
correct the reason 102 is separate is
that that is 100
general funds that's for uh board
we cannot use federal dollars to pay for
um
for board so that's why that's a
separate class line
the other thing you'll note is it looks
like there's a reduction here from
from 21 to 22. and
um in the general fund dollar request
for 22
there is but what is happening is we are
anticipating a carry forward
from 21 of about 38 million dollars
going into 22 and so that 38 million
dollars is not
reflected in our budget request because
it is a carry forward
but it will be part of the total budget
available for fiscal year 22 and and 23
to carry forward as well
because this accounting unit in last
biennium
was designated as a
revolving account so it is non-lapsing
um
and continuously appropriated
any questions there
i don't see any okay the next accounting
unit is
5947 which is program support
this is where the staff are for this
area
or some of the staff
so is more staffing anticipated
is that mostly increase or
um nope
i i actually think the the request from
21 to
22 is actually a decrease probably
because
of retirements dub's not so they would
have been budgeted at step
one in 22 because those were vacant
positions
and probably that's the other thing the
other thing to keep in mind
is that we're because of the closing of
the new hampshire designated receiving
facility
are zeroed out that's in a different
accounting unit though
yeah but just to i wanted to clarify
because i spoke about that but i wanted
to give everyone a heads up
yes
don't see any other questions okay
moving right along then uh the next one
is 5947
which is you know that's what i was just
doing i'm sorry
uh 7016 acquired brain disorder
known as abd for short
this similarly is anticipated to have a
carry forward which is why this is a
reduction here even from the actual
expenses in 2020.
okay you'll see that 22 or 23 rather is
more in line
um because that carry forward will be
used in 22.
yep i don't see any further questions
okay the next one is 7110
which is the ihf children's ihs
waiver
that appears to be up a bit is that
what is that
i'm sorry you weren't that appears to be
up a little bit is that
i'm sorry so
five or two the number the line appears
to be up about oh i don't know
some between five point six million and
seven and a half million
i'm reading that right or i'm sorry oh
i'm looking at the wrong i'm sorry
my columns are colored you know
different ways it's really level funded
from this year
is that accurate
it is it's down from fiscal year 21. yes
yeah i was looking at 20 when i never
mind keep going
okay
uh the next one is 70 uh 1-4
early intervention
this is not an accounting unit that
hasn't allowed carry forward it looks
like representative norgren might have a
question
right john oh yes thank you
um so we're seeing differences between
21 and 22 and 23
and and the the differences
in 22 uh are quite a few of them related
to
coven and the changing of
the status of people and serving
different people or
what do you think that is you're are you
referring to the developmental
disabilities
well i see it under children's waiver
acquired grade
so that that's because of the carry
forward um
that will be coming forward from 21 into
22. those
three accounting units are all
continuously appropriated non-lapsing
accounts and we're anticipating funds
that will not be spent in 21
that will carry over into 22. so those
those funds not spent were those because
of the pandemic or just
because they were inspect uh so i think
it was two things that was the pandemic
which deb spoke a lot
about earlier also this was the first
biennium
where we fully funded the wait list
so i think that it was also level
setting um what
fully funded might require okay thank
you
ken what were the three there were 7016
what were the other two that were the
carry forward
it's 7 100 71
6 and 71 10. thank you
and we are currently on 71.4 which is
early intervention
yeah i think i think you can go ahead
ken
okay uh this accounting unit 7164 is the
one that deb
spoke about the designated receiving
facility which um
does not have a budget for 22-23 as we
anticipate closing that
so that's the facility up in laconia
correct
okay because nhh is also
a d d d r f right
so the term designated receiving
facility is used in a lot of contexts
there are
different um types of drfs throughout
the state there
are mental health drffs this one was
specific to
the developmental disabilities community
okay
so it's a pretty universal term gotcha
thank you i'm learning
slowly it takes a long time
i don't see any other questions
okay the next one is 7013 which is
family support services
so this is one of the in-home ones
basically
dev can you speak to this accounting
unit and the family support services
so family support services um we find
families eligible
for waiver services and so this could be
somebody who is on the abd
ihs or dd waiver but they're also
eligible for fss
so through the 10 area agencies and the
services can include
respite um parent-to-parent advocacy
referral help
etc because one of the mainstays
of the developmental services system is
the fact that the families
in the majority of instances do the
heavy lifting
they provide the room they provide the
board they provide
the clothing and the supports and what
we try and do is help the families
continue to
do this and give them the support that
they need to get respite and take a
break and things like that
so this is an adjunct to the waiver
services and in some instances people
may not be
getting waiver services but they do get
family support services
so so it's in home the family's taking
care of someone in home that's why
they're getting the support
yes but in some instances they could be
in an enhanced family care and the
and the family continues to get some
level of family support because they
might be bringing them home on the
weekends for example
okay what we try and do is we try and
take care of
the people who provide the natural
supports so that we keep them engaged
and active in in being part of the
continuum of care themselves because
they do an
awful lot for the people we we support
and i probably shouldn't ask this again
because i know i heard it many many
times two years ago
but respite again could you just define
that for me
uh sandy can you define respite please
i thank you representative for the
question i'm sandy hunt
um the definition of respite is
a support service that's used to
basically
relieve the caregiver of providing care
to the individual whether that is
usually
in their home and you may have a respite
provider come in
to the caregiver's home or that
individual may go
to a respite provider's home but it's to
relieve the caregiver
essentially got it i've been dealing
with this one in law so yeah okay thank
you
great thank you
the next accounting unit is 78.52 which
is infant toddler program
this is 100 federal funds
love that
sometimes i don't love all the
compliance that comes with it i'm not
going to lie
now that's on you
i think we're good there it looks like
all right the next one is 7167 medicaid
compliance
i need i don't see any hands there
either okay
the next one is 78.58 which is social
services block grant for dd
ssb gene this is a a grant that we have
in many places in the department and all
federal funds isn't that one deployment
yes more work for can sorry
hey it's it's not bad work it's just
sometimes complicated
uh the next one is 5191 which is
special medical services
what are special medical services i see
it's roughly level funded
a little bit down them
right what i'm going to do is i'm going
to ask dee dunn who is the bureau chief
to explain
special medical services and the system
of care for children with special health
care needs
i haven't seen 562 before as a class
hi thank you um i'm deirdre don tierney
i'm the bureau chief for the bureau for
family centered services
and as i mentioned earlier one of our
three
areas of focus is special medical
services for children with special
health care needs
some examples of these services could
include health care coordination
where a nurse or social worker actually
helps the family to navigate the system
of care
for children with special needs they
sometimes have multiple
appointments or they need help
organizing transportation to get back
and forth
to specialty appointments we also offer
those clinics that deb spoke about early
child development clinic
family to family information center
nutrition feeding and swallowing to help
children who have difficulties with
maintaining nutrition
may have a failure to thrive they're not
growing or children that are using
feeding tubes
to make sure that they're getting
evaluations and services that they need
and and rejection in 22-23
uh i that
yeah so i was just going to say i don't
think it it's a it is a reduction from
fiscal year 21
um but it's bringing it more in line
with the actual spending that happened
in fiscal year 20.
is this all so careful it does not
thank you thank you
um
[Music]
sorry i'm pausing on unemployment
compensation because i think
that this should have been budgeted
department-wide so i'll check on that
and submit a change request on that
probably
um and that is the end of the accounting
units
okay
well thank you you're welcome we will be
back tomorrow with public health
okay sounds good looking forward
we have about 90 accounting units so
so i guess we're all done can i just
adjourn kevin or yes
yes you can you're all set looks like
representative norgren has a question
though oh i'm sorry i thought you're
waving goodbye representing organ go
ahead
in a minute so i would like to know what
the scenic
photo is that karen has a on her
face there so that is um
no bias but it's the best lake in new
hampshire it's newfoundland
i thought so yep that is the ledges
uh which have lots of history that road
part of the road wasn't built i believe
until the 60s
it's the deepest part of the lake
they've never been able to dive to the
bottom of the lake
anyway i'll stop now i could go on for a
while about how awesome
i thought i recognized that road yep
that's it
thank you kids tomorrow i'm supposed to
be at the uh
governor's council chamber at 8 30 so
i'll try to find a place to go online
for the state house or maybe with the
lba at 9 30.
okay very good we'll look for you
okay
bye